I'm actually on my way to go get these
fillers dissolved from my cheeks and
from my jawline because
enough is enough it all has to come out
I ain't even worry about us thinking I
just want it out
Blac Chyna is ready to go back to her
natural look I had to like come out show
out you know I'm doing good I'm uh just
feeling blessed right now China whose
real name is Angela White documented the
process of getting her facial fillers
dissolved in her cheeks jawline and lips
on Instagram
so excited about
taking these fillers out like what is
this
come on
how good is that what is that
throwba in the clip China tells the doc
that she's ready to dissolve it all and
go back to the Baseline first of all I'm
tired of the look and it's just not
flattering it's just not what I look
like it like totally changed my face and
I'm just I'm ready to get back to Angela
like Blac Chyna like black China is
black China you know what I mean and I
feel like I've outgrown that yeah and
it's just time for like a change the
model and former reality star notes that
when she would get her makeup done with
the fillers the look would be a little
too dramatic so I'll be looking like
light jigsaw
yeah that's a reference to jigsaw from
the 2017 horror flick
China shares the process of getting her
fillers dissolved and says the results
are almost instant explaining that her
face isn't as boxy as it was before but
this isn't the first time China has
opened up about reversing some of the
Cosmetic work she's had done
I'm in recovery mode right now got my
bandages on
as you can see
got my breasts reduced earlier this week
China who's 34 said she got her first
silicone enhancements when she was just
19. and spoke candidly about removing
what's left from her breasts and
backside
from the best decisions I could have
done in a very long time China is not
only changing the way she looks but
she's also pulling back on how much of
her we get to see she recently announced
that she's getting rid of her only fans
page which has reportedly made her
hundreds of millions of dollars
I just wanted to like just really focus
on me and I'm trying to set an example
for my kids China shares a 10 year old
son King Cairo with her ex Tyga and a
six-year-old daughter dream with another
ex Rob Kardashian Miss really definitely
uh been an experience like I'm really
like grateful and China says she wants
to be around for her babies another
reason she's done going under the knife
because you can get sick you can die
have complications and all this other
crazy stuff I haven't had any crazy
complications since I got up but now I'm
moving here in life so I'm like this out
of my
so I can grow
foreign